we start in pakistan where police have
filed terrorism charges against former
prime minister imran khan they are the
latest in a raft of legal proceedings
against the ousted leader you'll
remember khan was thrown out of office
through a no-confidence vote back in
april since then he's been eyeing a
return to power by holding a series of
mass rallies across the country to fire
up his base
khan has been steadily turning up the
rhetorical heat in his speeches
over the weekend he threatened to sue
the police and a judge after making
accusations that a political aid was
tortured in detention
they arrested my age
they kidnapped him
they took him into custody
stripped and beat him for three days
[Music]
[Applause]
i didn't know
after my lawyers visited him they
explained to me how badly the police had
beaten him
khan's irritation with the government
didn't end there he accused it of
attempting to silence him after
pakistan's media watchdog banned live
broadcasts of his rallies saying he's
spreading hate speech
this is what khan tweeted i quote the
fascist imported government
sunk to a new law today by banning live
coverage of my speeches on tv and then
blocking youtube temporarily during my
speech at lyaakadbag all these after
continuous intimidation of media persons
and taking channels off air
and joining me now for more context on
this is shamil champs from dw asia
shamil imran khan calls the government
of pakistan fascist and according to the
police has threatened law enforcement i
mean this is quite something coming from
a former prime minister what's behind it
well i must tell you that imran khan's
rhetoric is not aimed at prime minister
shabbat sharif's government
he's trying to put pressure on the
pakistani military because he knows that
they are the ones that call
the call the shocks he believes that the
army is behind the crackdown
and he wants to
put more pressure on on the military the
military general the army chief javed
bajwa
irresponsible for a former prime
minister but khan has never been a
traditional politician
so
that's what his supporters like about
him is populism and that's what he's
trying to do the public rallies
the rhetoric
all these things are aimed at putting
the military under pressure so that
they listen to his demands and the
demand is that
the government holds early elections
elections as early as possible
right and where does the military stand
when it comes to the present situation
in pakistan is it supporting the current
government or is it trying to be neutral
uh the military is apparently uh
supporting the current incumbent
government
uh which is uh the constitutional thing
to do because the military is supposed
to support the government
but that's not the only thing the
military has huge stakes in pakistan in
pakistan's economy
there is strategic issues the
geopolitical issues the military
believes it cannot allow a populist
politician to to sabotage all these
interests
and that's why they are trying to reign
in
uh the former prime minister imran khan
imran khan was ousted because he wanted
to influence the military he wanted to
bring in his own
military chief
and
that is that has not gone down very well
with the pakistani military top brass
these terrorism charges that have been
placed against imran khan will they
affect his chances of returning to power
i think the government prime minister
shabasha is the government is trying to
keep him quite for a while the most
important month in pakistani politics is
november when the new army chief will be
appointed or
the incumbent army chief will get an
extension
so until then you will see a lot of
political chaos in turmoil in pakistan
but the government is trying to keep him
quiet until november they also do the
army so that they can appoint the army
chief of their own choice and if that
happens there will not be early
elections in pakistan and imran khan's
chances to return to power will be very
very slim at least for
the coming two or three years
the scale of his rally seems to suggest
that he has a lot of support behind him
is the current government worried about
that support
uh imran khan remains a hugely popular
politician in pakistan there is no doubt
about it the rallies are huge uh since
his ouster his popularity has increased
the government incumbent i'm not sure
that are very worried about this because
they have the army's backing and that is
the most important thing in pakistani
politics unfortunately if the army is
supporting you then you are safe and
secure and at the moment the army is
supporting prime minister shabashi
shamil shams thanks so much always a
pleasure talking to you
fazana bari is a political analyst and
human rights activist based in islamabad
how well-founded would you say these
charges are legally speaking
i think it does
hold some grounds um
although
you know he used the word that
he will take like a case they will you
know
they will decide to take a have a case
against uh against the judge and uh
against the other uh you know
government officials uh but i think his
kind of stone tone was very threatening
um instead of in using that you know
they may appeal to the higher court you
know against the
judgment of the of the judge or the
design of the judge but he kind of use a
language and very threatening tone and
especially in the context of pakistan
where there are so few women who are in
our judiciary and he named that a woman
judge and said we are going to go
against you know
it will take we'll have a case against
her it was kind of a i think sort of
quite threatening and in that context
i'm sure there is legal people they can
tell better that whether it does qualify
as an anti uh you know um allegation as
anti um
sort of terrorist uh allegation which i
think is probably a bit too much uh but
i think he the way he has been
threatening um the government officials
and the state um institutions calling um
you know the way he's calling out i
think that's very inappropriate as for a
politician especially who served as a
prime minister of pakistan okay so from
what you're saying extreme reactions
from both sides how would you say the
case is being viewed in pakistan
i think
the society is completely there is a
total divide
and because i think this is kind of a
power struggle which is going within the
state and within these political you
know uh players um so you will see you
will find the both opinion on the both
sides there were people who will say um
you know he should be there should be a
case against him because he has been
actually um challenging the state and
the especially the judiciary and the um
pakistan army uh
you know of the country and then there
are people um who will say this is
within his right to you know within his
right to express and freedom of
expression that whatever he wants to say
he can he can say that so i think there
is a complete divide within the within
our society right now and within the
political circles as well as for uh you
know people are concerned does the
current government uh view the former pm
as a threat
absolutely they do um you know i think
they are also uh quite
wary of uh the kind of sport he's uh he
has and and his supporters were actually
um quite uh violent in the sense no you
know not uh physically but i think um
they uh they
keep threatening people and especially
in the social media uh they use very
abusive language uh against those who
are and
you know against uh against pti so i
think in that context also when he was
in power he has misused his power and he
has been also putting people in jail and
torturing and all that during his regime
that was happening um so i think the the
present regimes definitely um they are
also
they they do feel um you know uh
threatened also by um by him um and uh
therefore i think
probably that's why they want to now
take action against him because he's
keep on crossing the red lines you know
whatever those right lines are you know
but he is crossing that it hasn't been
happened i mean in the in the pakistani
politics you know we all know um the
establishment has been very
powerful you know even when there is a
civilian government at the back of that
you know it's always uh military uh
establishment who's calling the shorts
but i think um in in this case um now
this situation is that is
he is confronting his confronting that
is calling out but um you know in a very
different way like he's calling out he's
telling them that he should continue to
support him but they did you know back
in uh 2018.
so i think this is actually the
situation right now in the country
very interesting analysis there from
fazana bari in islamabad thank you